[Music]
I should be scared
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
sir what is this it's dog fight football
offensive defense at the same time
who's winning I think they stop keeping
scroll while I know
Detachment still has some training to
complete captain
every available minute matters yes sir
so why are we out here playing games
we said to create a team sir
there's your team
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that won't cover it
[Music]
uh
I'll come by tomorrow and bring you the
cash
I'm afraid
rules are rules paint
[Music]
[Applause]
ing
thanks for the beers come back anytime
[Applause]
myself
[Music]
is fine I'm good good expressions
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh no God
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
copy that
oh my gosh
where the hell is this guy
he's on our nose
smoke in the air rooster flares
that was close
we're out of flares map
[ __ ] he's already on us
oh this is not good
we took another hand no no no no no no
[Music]
take much more worse we can't outrun
this guy we gotta eject what we need
altitude pull the ejection handles the
second I tell you halfway booster
there's no other way foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
ladies and gentlemen this is your savior
speaking please fasten your seat belts
return your tray tables to their locked
and upright positions
and prepare for landing
hey hangman you look good I am good
rooster I'm very good
I'll see you back on Deck